ja und das verhalten was carina gerade
beschrieben hat bei sonnentor donets
schwamm gerade zeigt ist eben gar nicht
so und wisch es erinnert daran ja eine
unerwartete beendete liebesbeziehung und
dadurch lebt man eben phasen der trauer
verschiedene phasen die erste phase auf
jeden fall die phase leugnen und das
nicht wahrhaben wollen die zweite der
wut und des zorns und diesen
trennungsschmerz von trump wollen wir
uns jetzt mal genauer erklären lassen
von professor dr bandelow
er ist angstforscher guten abend herr
professor dr bandelow guten augen in
welcher phase was würde sagen befindet
sich denn jetzt gerade dann wenn man
nach diesen phasen der trauer geht eine
gemischte phase denn also den geschmack
den trennungsschmerz hatte einerseits
aber auch natürlich zorn und gut dass
verletzte ihn ja nie ganz und man muss
ja kein psychiater sein um ihm eine
narzistische persönlichkeit zu
attestieren und narzissten können eben
nicht verlieren deshalb auch vorher
schon gesagt ich bin ein ganz schlechter
verlierer und deswegen konstruieren tja
jetzt auch dass diese geschichte mit der
gestohlenen wahl wenn es wenn er sich
gar nicht mal unbedingt chancen
ausrechnet dass er damit durchkommt will
er trotzdem möglichst lange dieses
aufrechterhalten dass da so aussage
gegen aussage steht und das ja
eigentlich gar nicht verloren hat weil
er sich das selbst einfach nicht
eingestehen kann dass er verloren hat
aber was meinen sie wenn er sich in
einer gemischten phase gerade befindet
es nicht wahrhaben wollen und der wut
ist es schon die spitze des eisbergs
oder müssen wir uns noch mit schlimmerem
rechnen
also ich denke sein gehirn hat die ganze
zeit wie er sich jetzt rächen kann
anstatt dass er jetzt eine geordnete
übergabe an joe biden macht überlegt er
sich wie er sich rächen kann wieder im
das geschäft vermiesen kann wie mit
einem großen abgang noch aus dieser
nummer heraus kommt und das kann
durchaus noch gefährlich werden denn er
ist ja immer noch bis januar an der
macht
und wenn sie jetzt mit donald trump
sprechen könnten was würden sie aus
ihrer erfahrung her ihm raten was wären
ihre tipps an ihn
also ich würde wahrscheinlich sagen you
can to some people sometimes you can to
the people the times also das heißt man
kann zwar ab und zu mal ein paar leute
verkappten aber nicht immer alle leute
aber ich glaube durch das ja auf mich
hören würde weil er beratungsresistent
ist
ja das wäre zu befürchten viele an
professor dr bahnhof ihre einschätzung
danke ihnen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren